looking now at the race for secretary of
state here in nevada an interesting race
is developing here cisco aguilar joining
us running for the democratic side for
secretary of state it's good to meet you
thank you for having me i'm excited to
be here so for those who don't know tell
us about your background
why you're running for secretary of
state in the first place and just who
you are great i've been in nevada for
about 20 years now i'm an attorney spent
my first years with jim and beverly
rogers at channel 3. and then spent the
last 14 years with andre agassi and
stephanie graf
been there
for quite a bit it's quite exciting
why go into politics in this regard why
run for secretary of state secretary of
state is an interesting position because
it has two main responsibilities one is
you over your regulator of elections and
two you are the administrator for
corporate filings as an attorney at
agassi managing the corporate filings
for the years that it was there
it's pretty difficult sometimes to use
that system and it makes me think about
all the small business owners in las
vegas that have to use the system on an
annual basis
and they shouldn't have to hire an
attorney to use that system it should be
logical it should be functional it
should be easy to use and understandable
but still get the information that the
state needs for a business to remain
compliant and then on the election side
you are a regulator you are supposed to
be a neutral person advocating for all
voters in nevada it's not whether you're
a republican or a democrat it's giving
access to every nevada and the
opportunity to exercise their voice and
to be heard
we'll talk about the election component
in a moment because there's a lot to
that but just getting back quickly to
the the business and the licensure and
all of that those aspects of the
secretary of state that office handles
i've used the website before you're
talking about business owners and the
challenges they deal with what would you
like to implement just to make it easier
and more user-friendly
to just do your business absolutely i
think it goes back to a statement my
contract professor made in law school he
goes don't ever try to overcomplicate a
contract use plain language people
understand because if people understand
it you're going to be able to get to a
point of agreement quicker than if
you're using fancy or technical language
that not everybody understands on a
daily basis i think if we review the
processes that are in the system now and
try to make a more logical i think that
will make people happier let's now
switch to elections it's gotten a lot of
attention recently for obvious reasons
allegations by republicans of fraud and
challenges to the last major election
here back in 2020
some counties in the interim have moved
to hand counting most notably nye county
should the legislature pass a rule to
prevent that in future elections and i
guess more importantly are you a fan of
this hand counting change
in nye county and others no i'm not and
there's specific reasons why i think
hand counting there's a reason why
automation exists one it goes to the
fiscal responsibility of it it's
efficient it's accurate we have secure
elections in nevada our current
secretary of state barbara sagaski has
done a phenomenal job of ensuring our
processes are secure transparent and
open
and understanding her perspective
understanding why she made the decisions
she made is exactly why i want to run
for secretary of state somebody needs to
be in that position that is neutral and
understands that this position is not
about party it's about the state of
nevada and nevadans who want to exercise
their right to vote so well your
opponent in the race uh has certainly
made allegations
repeated ones that elections are rigged
in nevada and would implement changes of
his own if if he were elected
what how do you convince voters that
they're not rigged i think it's twofold
one is understanding what the current
secretary has done to investigate every
instance of alleged fraud and her
conclusions on why there was no fraud or
fraud did not exist second is our court
system you know being an attorney i
believe in the rule of law i believe in
our court system and i believe that our
judges have acted in an impartial way to
say that fraud has not existed in our
election cycles
the issue of voter id has also been
brought up in nevada a lot recently
is expected to probably come up again in
the legislative session that's upcoming
what is your stance on on implementing
some sort of voter id here in nevada you
know again it goes back to
are we looking for a solution to a
problem that doesn't exist
and if we can answer that question
fairly and neutrally i think we can have
a conversation however knowing what i
know and learning from the current
secretary of state and some of our
registers throughout the state
is i don't i think it's a solution to a
problem that doesn't exist however
you've got to go back to the basic
principle of what is voting is a
fundamental right that's guaranteed to
all americans and if you're going to
start to impede a fundamental right you
make we need to ensure that we
understand all the unintended
consequences of making such a hard
policy decision
would you suggest so that everything is
all fine the way nevada runs its
elections are there are you suggesting
there shouldn't be any changes at all
look as a business person and running a
business you're always looking for ways
to improve what you're doing it's always
looking for opportunities to improve
your efficiency always looking to
improve your security we can always look
at our processes and systems and do
reviews and do audits to ensure that we
are providing nevadans the best possible
election system we can
mentioning your opponent again who's
made some rather controversial election
conspiracy claims uh again rather
routinely
how do you respond to those claims if
you guys have end up debating or
something along those lines
how would you respond to those
to those
allegations
again i go back to what our current
secretary of state has done to ensure we
have secure and fair and open elections
again it's about the court system doing
a review of those being a neutral party
and reviewing those outside of the
secretary of state's office taking his
claim seriously and saying this is the
outcome and this is what we did not find
another uh issue with regards to
elections that's been there's been
signatures it went to the supreme state
supreme court ranked choice voting which
will be brought up again and if it
there's a long process before that
actually maybe does become law what is
your stance on the idea of potentially
bringing ranked choice voting into
nevada i think is really again it goes
back to unintended consequences before
we ever make a major policy decision or
you make a big business decision about
an investment you're always making sure
you understand the risk and you
understand the unattended consequences
i understand the reason behind ranked
choice voting however i think we need to
see how it plays out in alaska obviously
alaska is using right now currently in
its primary system new york city has
used it for its local elections and i
think we need to give nevadans a full
perspective on the issue it's not that
i'm against it or not for it it's just i
want to understand more about it before
we make a decision to implement it
across the state of nevada
all right
um i think that'll about do it for us we
thank you for joining us cisco aguilar
running for secretary of state here in
nevada looking forward to a very
interesting campaign thank you
appreciate it